imagine that day by day
your field of vision becomes slightly
smaller
narrowing or dimming until eventually
you go completely
blind we tend to think of blindness as
something you're born with
but in fact with many diseases like
retinitis pigmentosa
and ushers syndrome blindness can start
developing
when you're a kid or even when you're an
adult
both of these rare genetic diseases
affect the retina
the screen at the back of the eye that
detects light
and helps us see now imagine if the eye
could regenerate itself
so that a blind person could see again
to understand if that's possible
we need to grasp how the retina works
and
what it has to do with a multi-talented
creature
named the zebrafish the human retina is
made of different layers of cells with
special neurons
that live in the back of the eye called
rod
and cone photoreceptors photoreceptors
convert the light coming into your eye
into signals that the brain uses to
generate vision
people who have ushers syndrome and
retinitis pigmentosa
experience a steady loss of these
photoreceptors
until finally that screen in the eye can
no longer detect light
nor broadcast signals to the brain
unlike most of your body's cells
photoreceptors don't divide and multiply
we're born with all the photoreceptors
we'll ever have
which is why babies have such big eyes
for their faces
and part of why they're so cute but that
isn't the case for all animals
take the zebra fish a master regenerator
it can grow back its skin bones heart
and retina after they've been damaged
if photoreceptors in the zebrafish
retina are removed or killed by toxins
they just regenerate and rewire
themselves to the brain
to restore sight scientists have been
investigating this superpower
because zebrafish retina are also
structured very much like human retina
scientists can even mimic the effects of
disorders like ushers syndrome
or retinitis pigmentosa on the zebrafish
eye
this allows them to see how zebrafish go
about repairing their retinas
so they might use similar tactics to fix
human eyes one day too
so what's behind the zebrafish's
superpower the main players are sets of
long cells that stretch across the
retina
called muller glia when the
photoreceptors are damaged
these cells transform taking on a new
character
they become less like molar cells and
more like stem cells
which can turn into any kind of cell
then these long cells divide
producing extras that will eventually
grow into new photoreceptors
travel to the back of the eye and rewire
themselves
into the brain and now some researchers
even think they've found the key to how
this works
with the help of one of two chemicals
that create activity in the brain
called glutamate and amino acid
in mouse eyes these make the molar glia
divide and transform
into photoreceptors which then travel to
the back of the retina
like they're replenishing a failing army
with new soldiers
but remember none of this has happened
in our retinas yet
so the question is how do we trigger
this transformation of the muller glia
in the human eye
how can we fully control this process
how do photoreceptors rewire themselves
into the retina and is it even possible
to trigger this in humans
or has this mechanism been lost over
time in evolution
until we tease apart the origins of this
ability retinal
regeneration will remain a mysterious
superpower
of the common zebrafish
you